hello
and we're back i think
with a brand new episode of the same
thing you were just watching before it
got interrupted
the funny thing is
hello
let me just press the spacebar
the funny thing
is i uh
disconnected and reconnected the wi-fi
and didn't expect it to work but then it
did
now here i am blabbering in front of you
folks like
i
have something to say
um yeah i mean weight cutting in the ufc
it's just an interesting uh thing that's
happening
so i was making a point
[Music]
in front of uh
esteemed colleagues and gentlemen of the
of high society
and i kind of made an ass out of myself
so let me
try to reiterate what was happening this
is even going out anywhere what the [ __ ]
so um
the whole thing i was trying to say
is that
why are these
libs
and feminazis
why
why are they trying to
uh why do they why are they indifferent
about the plight of the tra of the women
in sports and trying to shove
transgenders into every little
sport they their
filthy little grubby little
hands their little
uh you know soft hands
that how many can they they can find why
are they trying to do that
and i think it's because they don't care
about women
no they do care about women i think it's
because they don't care about
sports sports to them it's like whatever
who gives a [ __ ] sports uh yeah let's uh
sports oh it's beautiful it's art it's
just people expressing themselves why
can't this person this transgender
person with
45 45-inch biceps and a giant [ __ ] why
can't this person express themselves the
way that they want they think everything
is gymnastics or rupaul's drag race so
they don't respect the artistry
and the idea of fair play
like you know [ __ ]
crazy ass trump supporters would
oh my god i need to find a spot that has
not only rock but wood so these [ __ ]
people they don't give a [ __ ] about
sports they don't understand it they
don't watch it so they don't just they
just don't [ __ ]
they don't care if it hurts sports
sports is whatever sports is
you know
just a thing and it's like who cares put
let let jonathan play let
ruby play she wants to play your little
sporty things
and
so they um they they try to shove their
way in but you got to understand these
[ __ ] trump supporters they're
economically depressed
they are destitute they are
sad sad people and they have nothing to
entertain themselves but these little
games
and distractions
if you take that away from them they get
really really really offended
and you know
whatever
so don't do that
just let him [ __ ]
do that whatever
okay
let him have their sports let's let them
decide what a woman is
in sports you can decide what a woman is
in [ __ ] whatever whatever else you
want
just don't do that with the [ __ ]
thing
oh my god i don't know where i'm gonna
put this [ __ ] i'm guessing here
and then i'm gonna build here to get
that wood
but how how will i ever get all the way
over there
oh god i could build here
and go this way and then try to beat red
should i try to [ __ ] over red try to get
this sheet port
that might be a more fun way to play
um
um
um um um um
um
[ __ ]
now i just need a brick or two sheep
which one did he put down second
he might already have a road so i might
need a road
right away
i might have just [ __ ] myself
oh [ __ ]
nine
eight eleven
i think you put down this one second
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
i need to try
anyways
so if bodies of waters always find the
level and lay flat on this and the earth
is over then isn't the earth actually
flat
what the [ __ ] is this guy doing
um
oh [ __ ] oh what a [ __ ] idiot
holy [ __ ] he could have [ __ ] me
so hard
and he just totally didn't
what a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
so
yo yo greetings from finland wow
is everything perfect there
why is it so grainy over here
because it's wrinkled i need to steam
this [ __ ]
or iron it i should buy an iron
dude no one has two
oh my god i needed [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh
[ __ ] dude
oh god
no one
does anyone have a brick
i need a bricky brick
okay that's a good start i need another
eight or ten and then i can build a
brick i can build a road and
have success
come on [ __ ]
okay
not what i need
come on
[ __ ]
so i mean do i think leah thomas
should be fighting in the goddamn
whatever
thing
um
should should she be
running around doing her [ __ ]
being gay and stuff
um no
i don't think she should
i think what she should do
is relax
and swim with people
that are not
women
sorry
you don't get to do that
i think
that
it's all great
that you want to be inclusive but
in this realm
liberals you're out of your depth you
don't know what you're talking about
you are
wrong
lol
you cannot have that and be a fair
competition you should always favor fair
play
and uh women
or whatever
or whatever
isaac
marion de souza says get a job that's
like a slave being seeing a free person
being like be a slave why aren't you a
slave right now
don't you want to be told what to do and
have a schedule
that is controlled by someone else don't
you hate
doing whatever the [ __ ] you want all the
time
um i have not had a real job
since i was 23
24 maybe i'm 32 right now that is
nine years of not giving a [ __ ] you
think i could go back to that
shitty little
stupid little way you guys live i'm not
like you people i'm a completely
different animal
i'm like
i'm crazy
i can't i can't get a job
so yeah you know
this is the nature of the beast
um
yeah i'm not gonna get a job why do you
need a job
what is a job
to you what do you think that means
why would a why would anyone need a job
like to make a living and all that why
don't you just say make a living
but that's not what these [ __ ]
say they say get a job because they want
everyone to do what they're doing
they want everyone to be living the same
way and suffering in the same way
and it ain't gonna happen bro
i'm free
free balling
i'm balling with much freedom
i do exclusively comedy
i
do exclusively podcast i exclusively
do whatever the [ __ ] i want and anything
else it would be a travesty oh this
[ __ ] is trying to get at my
sheep
this [ __ ]
um
yeah
i'm not gonna get a job no thank you
bye bye
oh [ __ ] orange used a
knight
these people [ __ ] take forever
um but yeah i mean if you love jobs and
that's your thing as having a job then
you are totally allowed to do that
but i would not advise it i think it's
very
defeating and
bad for your soul
um but
yeah i mean if you like doing something
then i don't know if you have to be told
what to do all the time
um
but yeah i mean
this should be a way to
you know live your life with freedom and
happiness
oh god i want that eight
i want that spot so bad
hey
bill clinton
i want that spot so bad
i just need a [ __ ]
[Music]
sheep kahan has
these
six cards what does kahan have
khan got wood
come on
got brick
cajon has wood two wood one brick
three wood one brick
one rock
one sheep
i think he has enough to build a
settlement
what should i do
anyways
so
can't see the game
oh sorry
my beautiful face was in the way
if you don't do didn't you call me what
would you do then
i would probably be
some sort of terrorist
no jk
i would probably be a freedom fighter in
colombia
what would i do if i wasn't doing comedy
i would probably be a musician or an
artist or a painter or a
graffiti painter
i don't like music music i don't think
is a good industry because it's too much
about looks
and
i'm not
i don't think i'm a looker
i'd rather not try to emphasize my looks
hans i'm telling you man you got to play
katan in vr oculus quest 2. well some
guy said he was sending me one so
if that happens i will
it's not like i'm not doing it because i
hate the idea of it
um sunstorm built a thing
not three wheat for no reason
what i really need is wood
and to [ __ ] cajon over in any way
possible to prevent him from
oh yeah baby
let me [ __ ] over kahan again
kahanagan
kahan
sheep
and now
my watch has ended
uh music is to
look spaced
why am i getting so much wheat there's
so many fives rolled i don't know if
this is a real randomized thing
i don't think it's completely randomized
oh my god
what is it that i wanted to do i don't
know
do i want to trade with red no
i do not want to trade with red even
though he's offering me a juicy juicy
[ __ ] deal for wheat which i have too
much of
but i don't want to help him because he
might build a little thing right there
oh god i'm so far away from building
over there
i'm so [ __ ] far away
i need wood i need brick
i want to [ __ ] him over so bad
it's gotta happen man
i need to [ __ ] him over
blue
blue's not a threat
is he is he trying to build
on my beautiful eight
i have one road i need two roads
okay
did not help
at all
uh
do i want to do something rash
should i get a brick
okay that's my turn
sheep
it's just nice i guess
six is he gonna build a settlement does
he have enough
he's not asking oh he's asking for a
trade he really needs brick
what a thirsty [ __ ]
what a thirsty little [ __ ]
blue has a brick because i have a brick
does he oh no i traded for that brick
look how thirsty this [ __ ] is
damn
jesus christ what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyways hopefully the computer doesn't
trade with this [ __ ]
wait
yo [ __ ]
either he's trying to build a city
and needs one more wheat or he's trying
to build a
settlement and needs one more brick
but he cannot under any circumstances be
allowed to get that brick
he needed it so bad so if a three is
rolled it's been
oh oh no
okay well let's hope he forces sevens
himself
okay another [ __ ]
wheat
what the [ __ ] am i supposed to do with
this [ __ ]
i'm gonna save this all just in case
some [ __ ] goes down
okay
and now i wait
oh [ __ ] he's got two brick now oh [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
all i needed was two more wood and one
more brick
oh [ __ ] now what's he doing
where is he going now is he going for
that
why does he need so much sheep
hey [ __ ]
okay
i still need two more wood and one more
shape
and it's gonna be hard
sheep
and wood
ah sure
okay
now i need
one more wood and one more brick and one
more
whatever
damn he's got five points
seven
[ __ ] over orange
sheep
jeep
anyways i'm uh
online i guess
um
hans
right on man keeper
what the [ __ ] hans i love you hans love
seeing you on kill tony never dipped my
toes into contempt but i've played
similar games hanzo races
sc2 protoss
the thing i like about katan is that it
makes sense it's oh [ __ ]
this guy's coming at me
this [ __ ]
i do not need wheat why do i get so much
[ __ ] wheat
it's [ __ ] crazy
oh come on you [ __ ]
jesus [ __ ]
oh he needs wheat
i have so much wheat if only you weren't
such a oh no
traded with this [ __ ]
oh he needs wood too
jesus why is everyone training with him
and not me
okay i have enough for a [ __ ] thing
now as long as i don't get sevened
i should be good
i really want to [ __ ] over
red
okay don't get sevened
okay
that's fine
oh i could [ __ ] over red so hard as long
as i don't roll a seven right now
oh please god
please lord oh lordy
oh no
no
no way
what the actual [ __ ]
um i could do this and try to get a
sheep
or i could do this
i'll do this
this seems more sneaky
let's [ __ ] over
at red
because he deserves it oh
yes i will
you saw victory and what
patience and hard work gets you just now
this is a victory for happiness
and positivity
this little guy right here this rep is
this is
this i'm going to call this jamestown
my city on a rock
this is my beauty right here look at
this beautiful little [ __ ]
i'm totally encapsulated him into this
little area
and now he can be no more
he is done for
i have
finished him
with my strength of a seven the seven i
thought was my downfall but in fact it
was
not my downfall it was my upfall
it's just a game
why are you so mad it's just game
um so i have the sheet port i have the
three to one port
oh where am i gonna put this now
probably on this [ __ ] he has six
points
this guy's five this guy's
uh
no this guy's a threat
yeah baby
should i get this or should i save up
for a city
so bro how are you four people only
watching this you're the future i've
been telling you it doesn't matter how
many people are watching it now
um
i would love it if more people watched
um
but
yeah whatever
i mean just because i'm in the future
doesn't mean what i'm doing right now is
entertaining
uh
but
i know it's
the name of the game or
whatever um i'm trying to make it
entertaining i'll try to be funny and
insightful
do i need wheat i don't really need
wheat
how am i not getting any sheep
this is ridiculous
sevened himself
well it didn't hurt help that i got
disconnected and had to reconnect again
oh you know what i forgot
to use this maybe this is why only four
people are watching
because i forgot a very important part
of camera work
and you're going to see it soon
um
turns out this thing is crooked
lights
look at me
oh the lighting helps the fuzziness go
away
look at me i look like i'm in a [ __ ]
whatever
it's gonna be morning soon
it's gonna be crazy
man you crazy
okay i mean i really can't connect these
two together
so
wow
a lot of cards that i don't really have
a use for wow
i don't need brick
or weight
or sheep
nobody knows the struggle i've seen
nobody
know the struggle
i've seen
would
wouldn't you like to know
what
what
oh red
should i trade with red
what do you say
um
i say
okay oops
too late
oh there we go now i have nine cards
and i could be seven
damn how many twelves have been rolled i
don't know how random this [ __ ] is
okay
interesting
wheat
he'll give me wood
okay i'm down for that
jesus everyone's at six points but me
seven
jesus
he's the winner now he's the winning now
ooh
thought i would get sevened
okay let's
do this little
maneuver
look at that works
either this
or this
doesn't really matter to me
does it really matter
to me
[Music]
just gained two points
i'm a [ __ ] awesome person
i'm really really cool
mama
i'm gonna win
[Music]
okay so
here's the deal uh how did you did you
tell your parents or the people you
loved
that you're going to be a comic and live
in a van congrats on ditching the van
life everyone's like oh you must be so
relieved that you don't live in a van
anymore how awesome is it that you don't
do that i
don't think it was that bad
i am not that it wasn't like a huge
thing for me
holy [ __ ] oh the light died
for me to not live in a van
i think that
i mean people are like isn't it sad that
you have to live in a van yeah it is sad
that this society is [ __ ]
um
but yeah i mean i think
the
the fact that i had to do it
is a testament to the society that we
live in
and
not as much of a thing about
so from kahan
seven nine okay well yeah i gotta steal
from this [ __ ]
this guy has these points
that no one can take away from him
jesus
what the [ __ ] you [ __ ]
he has nine points
and he took away from the guy who had
six points
blue has nine points
as if i have to say that shouldn't it be
obvious shouldn't you be paying
attention to the game that you're
playing
um
one two three four
i mean
i can you get two little thingies
i don't even remember how to buy a
development card it's i'm
i need to go to sleep
but
i could build right here
one two three four
get a road
and then
do that or
i could do this
i got a development card for no reason
um do i want to build a road
or i got a development card
um if i build a developer okay i'm gonna
do that
and that's how the gun lord works
you know what i like to do
asian and he has small little eyes
let's be racist to asians online
and people
will just think that i'm a horrible
person
but it's like i'm asian oh and it's my
real name so
and this is just like what i'm go to
saying about myself these cheap asian
jokes so it's like
it comes easily for me
they're like how dare you you're being
so racist
but yeah it's like i am asian and they
don't know that
orange
orange is not a threat
i am not a threat i have
the least amount of points
um but hopefully they don't hate me
he's saying gg already
so rude
i hate it when people say gg
preemptively holy [ __ ]
oh my god
well do it buddy
what do you do use your plenty
you got longest road maybe oh you got
longest road
looks like
i lost i really want to play another
game
um
oops
started another one should i cancel
i'm gonna be up so late it's gonna be
crazy
how late i'm gonna be up
as you'll see here
um
let me pull up a cool background
uh
that's a cool
rain
screen
background
yeah
why is this thing such a piece of [ __ ]
green screen
uh background
video
all these [ __ ] no copyright things
say they're
no copyright but some of them are
why don't i because if i use a youtube
video it'll get pulled or demonetized
right
um
royalty free
what's a cool thing skiing video
let's just play this on a loop
what is this cool thing to be sitting in
front of sienna
and square
uh images
takes forever to load what the [ __ ] open
a new tab
let's just do this one this will confuse
people
make it bigger open image in new tab and
zoom in
now i'm in front of tiananmen square
okay what's going on here
so this is a
13 spot
this is a 12 spot that he took
this is an 11 spot
i'm gonna go with this one honestly
and i need brick
and i need wheat
i could build here
there's not a lot of things going on
over here
so i might build up here
or i might pull down here i'm going to
build
up here i think
and get that wheat somewhere
okay
tiananmen square let's try to
make this
official
look at me i'm in tiananmen square
isn't that cool
live from tiananmen square hans kim
known communist
it's good to be here in the center of
communism
mao zedong
hey mal what do you think about the uh
cultural revolution and how like all
those people died because you starved
them to death
oopsie
sorry
my bad
i made a little mistaking mistake
oops
i accidentally tried to modernize my
country too fast
and a whole bunch of people died
but yeah i mean what are you gonna do
right
it's this country
so
you know let's let him do it
but i mean honestly
mao zedong
i mean he didn't modernize china or i
guess
that pain thing
whatever did
but uh
he helped
mao zedong helped and uh
helped his country gain independence
and uh you know was like now china is
like its own unique thing
no matter what you say at least they did
it their way you can't say they weren't
unique
they did have some panache and pizzazz
cream of some young guy
um but yeah i mean
i just like the fact that the whole
world was like no don't do that china
you're doing a bad thing and china was
like
we do not care
we do not care
we are china
i don't know how to write chinese accent
anymore
my friend i am chinese i will do
whatever the [ __ ] i want
dude what
what is he doing is he just purposely
trying to [ __ ] me in the ass
i can get nine points now
going this way
maybe i should not have done what i did
but i done did it
now he has everything he needs
and 9.9 dots
i have 13 dots starting out
he has nine dots so that is four more
dots
then his
most populous spot
nine plus four
thirteen plus 3 is 16 dots
16 dots i already have 13. i just need
to find a spot with three dots and i'll
be b oh
god damn that's why i should never take
that risk never build towards the center
you will always get [ __ ] in the ass
i need brick and wheat
breaking wheat
anybody have breaking wheat
how am i gonna get break in this
situation
zoom ghosted boom toasted boom roasted
um i don't know who's saying
who's getting roasted about what but
i think i know my spot
i think i see it
five nine ten dots right here
this is
six
four less dots but i get a weight brick
should i do this spot with a rock port
or this spot with no rock port but a
whole shitload of wheat
it's a tough choice but i'm gonna have
to go with the whole shitload of points
this is ten this is four more dots
i need those four dots
uh four more dots four more dots four
more nuts i could get the sheep port and
get a lot of wood
um but then it's hard to get more sheep
so i got that way
i kind of like
this
wheat
then i can get wood but it's hard to get
more wood
here so where's the wheat port all the
way over here
okay if i build here
i can't get more rock here i can get
more rock here if this guy cooperates
and i'm gonna just go here
and then i'm gonna build
towards the three to one
i'm gonna be the three to one guy
okay whatever
i'm not gonna have brick this game
brick is so important and special
um
yeah i mean everyone says i'm
consistent and
yes i am
there's nothing i am
if i'm not consistent
how could i be anything else but
consistent it is who i am and what i am
made of is consistency every time i go
on kill tony is consistent
so that's the kind of thing that i tried
to foster and
uh whatever i'll be right back it's cool
okay
okay i run
this
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
you guys saw that [ __ ]
yeah with the light on
it's almost perfect how [ __ ] green
screened it is
i feel like i'm in catan
life in katan is great
i live inside katan
open a book
stuck on my [ __ ] i live in katana more
land i'm here
i
do love catan what
it's all you need is a game of katan
don't get any friends play katanto 5 am
6 am
it's all about katan
[Music]
man what a [ __ ] awesome person i am
playing katan so [ __ ] much
i need it man
[Music]
someone please give me a [ __ ] rock
what am i gonna do if i don't have a
rock
why would you no one what the [ __ ] i
don't need any of this
um
blue says yes
thank you blue your efforts shall be
rewarded
in some
handsomely
13 obviously here
dude i got that 13 dot
you all [ __ ] with that 13 dots that
was 13 dots
sounds like some communist thing
uh 13 dots remember the 13 dots
look at that sexy city
this is my city i shall call it
taco town
do you get to spend much time with rogan
after the shows and all of that
yes i spend so much time with rogan it's
bonkers
i am super privileged to do it and i
love it
um
[Music]
yeah i spent a lot of time with rogan
i mean i watched this podcast so much
i'm only a few months
into comedy and curious why is it rarely
crowd riffing improvised sets on kill
tony
versus most comedy
shows why is it really crowd roofing it
provides sets on kilt i don't know what
the [ __ ] you're saying
yes tony is a goat
he's paving a path for comedians dog
okay
i'm trying to understand this question
why is there not a lot of riffing and
improvised because it's stand-up comedy
i think if you want improvised sets you
should do improv
like comedy is the process where you
think of something funny you write it
down and then you say it improv is where
you go up there with not an ounce of
anything funny you just hope that
something happens that is funny that you
can just take some random [ __ ] like
you know
a toaster and then you can make that
funny like what
tell some jokes you know
let's get at it
let's write it down let's figure out
what's the funniest thing and then say
that instead of just random ass [ __ ]
but uh yeah i think the reason why
people
don't riff and improv so much in
stand-up comedy
are you asking like improvised sets on
kill tony versus most comedy shows
uh yeah a lot of his humor is like
tony's humor is improvised but a lot of
stand-up comedy is not and a lot of tony
stand-up comedy is written jokes and uh
he's amazing at both so yes tony's ago
he's picking a path for comedians
you shouldn't just assume hanzi's goats
and dogs and dog consulted disagree
did someone steal from me
um
i don't know
yeah i mean
it is possible to
not to have improvise or that improv is
funny but
it's more probable that improv and up is
funny and you know
improv is just for like
like flittering people who can't have a
concrete idea in their head and they'd
be distracted by something shiny all the
time
um
oh you [ __ ]
um i think that uh if you actually want
to delve deep into an idea it helps to
think about it beforehand and it's hard
to
you know
delve into an idea if you haven't
written it out before and if you have an
amazing thought before
you get on stage which is most of your
life
uh
then you should be able to say it and
like
if you uh
if you can't
if you if you can't use the wealth of
knowledge that you gained before and you
can only use it in a second-hand way
it's going to be less funny i think i'm
probably
[ __ ]
but uh why is there not a lot of improv
uh why don't you do improv then why are
you doing stand-up comedy do improv if
you love improv and riffing so much
stand-up comedy is using the benefit of
the ability to write to make a better
set
um but yeah i mean i do love
riffing and improv i just don't think
it's like some people like jizz in their
pants for that [ __ ] and it's like oh my
god he made this moment so funny and
usually this moment is just full of my
dad and my mom and just of violence and
chaos and i'm just so glad that someone
can turn this
horrible reality in the moment to
something
slightly better and
devoid of negativity
and full of positivity
but like that you shouldn't just try to
be
positive you should also like create
something
you should like
think of stuff and come up with ideas
and
uh
figure your [ __ ] out and delve deeply
into an idea instead of just [ __ ]
you know just trying to
gain happiness and positivity any way
you can because your life is so lacking
of that
um but yeah i mean there's a place for
improv and riffing i just don't favor it
it's not my style
uh
and i think that's fine was i supposed
to put this
this [ __ ] on the anchors
you sound salty yet as [ __ ] for other
comics who don't have a scripted set
yeah i do i'm salty as [ __ ] comics that
don't have a scripted set because it
sucks and i hate watching them
bumble [ __ ] their way around my
beautiful stage
it's mine
i
can't go
anywhere
it's in a book suck my [ __ ]
improv
sucks if improv was good they would have
written it down and
practiced it and done it over and over
again
um but yeah i mean i i think improv is
great if you want to do it i think you
should be allowed to do it i don't think
there should be a limit to it but the
reason why
i don't
reconnection's successful
um katan
tan where are you
[Music]
two i got a [ __ ] two
the [ __ ] am i gonna do with this
[ __ ]
i need to get rid of this [ __ ]
i
can't go
anywhere
come on [ __ ]
orange orange don't be a [ __ ] dick
come on orange
okay you know what i'm willing to do
this for you [ __ ]
this guy keeps proposing trades that are
ridiculous
i should have done that i should have
waited for him
it's in a book
raining rainbow
i mean best comics go off the top they
are entertainers in minneapolis
i'm in minneapolis nothing more lame
than hearing comics say the same set up
some punchline a weeks a week
you think a week is a long time
you really uh
have been doing comedy for three months
um i think that
what are the best comedy specials
richard pryor
um you know bill burr louis ck
any of those
holy improvised sets
are they wholly written down
what are the best jokes
i mean i think some people love improv
because
that's all they have
they don't want to sit down and write
and they're not serious and they can't
keep an idea in their head long enough
to write it down
and they're um you know sad little
people
and i think impersonalized great
i'm just talking [ __ ] um but your 10th
favorite standard versus best episode of
who's line ever real stand up is better
whose line is it anyways yeah i mean how
much of that can you it's transferable
can you go up to someone and be like
well on whose line is it anyway they
said i'm a little teapot
uh
why is that supposed to you know is that
supposed to
engender a coalition and start a
movement
however if you go up to someone and
you're like [ __ ]
george carlin said the seven dirty words
that you can't say or blah blah blah
blah blah
or like
bill hicks was like have you ever
stepped over a homeless man and thought
to yourself man this system isn't
working
uh he did it better or like i used to do
drugs i still do but i used to too
oh thanks alex
varujas she says my interviews are funny
i think so too
a lot of people disagree but
really
who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] about what these
[ __ ]
goombas say
it's really just about me me me me
man
i am having so much fun just thinking
about myself
oh you [ __ ]
dude everyone has four points everyone
has four points
relax
bro
jesus christ
these [ __ ] people
improv is for the sociopath
interview equals improvised
i i don't like improv
i just don't
i'm sorry
i like people who think about things
i
can't go
anywhere
uh blue blue is annoying me
he's getting too close for comfort blue
has six cards
let me take some of that
[ __ ] i needed that too
let me get some wood
give me some wood boy
put it up what up
um let's see if alex
interviews are the best part i killed
tony yes sir yes
interviews are the best part to kill
tony i mean
they're they're a great part of kill
tony but without the stand up
you know kill tony wouldn't be what it
is
i understand that you love improv and
that you love
people
being really successful without trying
very hard
but i just don't i like effort i like
people who try hard and to see people
who try hard succeed because i think the
ceiling is higher
i call tony is the best part of kill
tony yes alex you're right but people
have a chance to do something in there
yeah like if there wasn't that minute
then it would just be an interview show
um oh my god what the [ __ ] why does
everyone everyone's just been gone so
used to [ __ ] me
stole my sheep
you steal my sheep
um
yeah i mean uh improv is great dude go
do improv
you're three months in you probably know
how to do comedy
just trust your instincts and if you
don't want to do improv if you don't
want to write jokes that's fine you know
you just do improv all day
no i think uh you can do improv if you
want no one's telling you not to it's
just like
i don't know why don't you just do
improv
why are you doing stand up then why are
you doing stand up and then doing improv
just to improv and do improv
um but you know you can do
stand up and improv and stand up and
just do crowd work the whole time
um
that's possible you can do whatever you
want it's an open mic that's the
beautiful thing about comedy is there's
so many different styles and you can do
whatever you want
my style happens to be
you know
[ __ ] on improv
what's the best comedy advice you have
received is don't take comedy advice
from anyone
which i took
so i guess i didn't follow oh my god
please everybody
there
are more people to steal from than me
i mean you can steal from me but i'm
gonna be annoying about it
because everyone's stealing from me
it's not fair
i don't like it
it's gonna give me [ __ ]
wheat
imma i'm gonna have to take this
because otherwise i ain't getting
what i need
blue oh [ __ ] i shouldn't have traded
with blue he's gonna build a settlement
right here
thankfully he's poor as [ __ ]
before getting a break how long did you
grind the open mics before getting a
break
what do you consider a break
like being able to make money from
comedy is like
two months ago and i've been doing it
ten years ten mo ten years nine years
kill tony the show is the best part to
kill tony the show the podfather we're
getting a break
um okay tony is the best particular i
don't know what's happening anymore
um
i could build towards here on the off
chance that blue is
[ __ ] fucktarded
but
i don't want to take that oh
[ __ ]
now whatever
okay
i need
a wood
anyone need any of this
oh fine
you can build a settlement there [ __ ]
i won't even try to go down there then
um
when am i gonna have my parents on kill
tony oh my god kill tony with oh why are
you stealing from me
i guess i am winning
stole my wheat
god damn [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
dude everyone is stealing from me
what have i done to you people
um
i only missed job from the la kill tony
band
well joel was a great part of kill tony
joel berg joel jimenez um
he was great at coming up with jokes on
the flames just be listening in the back
like when can i say a pun
dude how does this guy not seven himself
okay go ahead build your little thing
[ __ ]
dude this guy's five
[ __ ] things
god damn
one two three
four
i loved jeremiah he was great
some of his riffs took too long
um
i loved
i loved a lot of different people on
that show
it was a great time you know i used to
watch that [ __ ] every day especially
during the pandemic i'll go through the
old episodes and i love the quarantine
episodes too
and i would uh watch that [ __ ] because
it was like being at an open mic and
that's my life is that open mics and i
couldn't go to open mics anymore
i mostly miss the band being diff
characters every week yeah it was like
fun
it was a nice distraction it was like a
cool thing i guess but i mean
if that's the best part of the show then
that's probably not good
because like any show can have people
dress up as different characters
um you probably want something more than
that
oh thank god
i can finally relieve myself of this
thief
but i need to get the longest road
that's kind of what i want which is
going to be difficult without brick
and it's going to be really hard for me
to get brick
i'm in his army six points what to do oh
thank god he relieved me of it
he's going after blue now right
yes
[ __ ] blue
um
inextricably linked to blue he [ __ ]
over right he should have gone to this
eight right here to [ __ ] over blue
god
that's [ __ ] momo
uh
i think uh kill tony is a great show and
we should do everything to help spread
the word of it
and to make it a better show by
you know signing up for it and
watching it and
you know
whatever everything any and all of it
do it
let's get it out there
bow
i got a foe
i can get a rock as long as i don't
seven myself
and then i can get a
[ __ ]
thing
oh nice i don't have to do anything like
that
should i rob him i'm gonna wait until
that shit's annoying me and then
he's so close he already has the longest
road
that's gonna be hard to beat
hard to beat meat
oh so many sheep let me see if some
loser wants to trade with me
i really can't trade with anyone but red
and he already refused my offer of
marriage
i'ma just build right here
call it a day
dude this guy has six development cards
what the [ __ ] is he doing under there
orange
orange you glad
you didn't use up all your cards hey
hans how's your parents where do they
live bro here in the states yeah one of
them does one of them lives in korea i'm
not going to tell you where in korea or
where in america
but
yeah
i mean
they live in oakland
oh
steal from blue thank you
okay i'm still gonna move it because
it's annoying me now
i'm gonna try to [ __ ] over
blue
just because i don't like the cut of his
jib
i could put it on that
wheat so that he can't build any cities
or buy development cards
that should also [ __ ] over
orange but he already has a six
or i could [ __ ] over his wood he has a
three to one port
um but yeah my family's great
i feel like people can tell a lot about
people
as they um
if you want to tell a lot about people
as a
from their family
so they want to see it oh my god he has
eight development cards that's so
useless you can only use them once a
turn and he hasn't used any
this guy's ridiculous did i already roll
the [ __ ] is going on
how long has this turned been
he just moved that [ __ ]
year of plenty to build the road
orange
dude what is orange doing
he got stuff for a road but then didn't
blow the road
got four br for wheat
that's good
but i don't have the port blue
got the uh seven
flea doesn't steal from me hopefully
steals from orange
orange and i share this so you can put
it here [ __ ] both of us
um
that sounds nice korea's one day
where i want to go you know travel and
visit your culture dog i love all people
that's not something i want to hear
when someone's like yeah love you
i love you
my beautiful girlfriend
i love you wife i love all people
yeah even like stupid ugly dumb cultures
i love
so yeah i love you
i love your culture too
dude that guy has eight [ __ ]
points dog
what am i gonna do with that
i need to [ __ ] him over
and hard
i need to [ __ ] him in the ass
um
i guess i'm gonna build a settlement
there
i need a brick
brick me up
broski
cannot trade with blue
blue is too close to winning
um
oh i can't do that i guess
rick
i need to do something
nothing to see here
oh i should have just saved that brick
i'm going to need it
if i want to build anything over there
all asians matter what's wrong with a
man who loves another man am not gay nor
bi nor straight up
but love is the strongest
who the [ __ ] is stealing from me
they stole it
seven sheep
um
that's fine by me
there are only two question marks on
that sheep
so there weren't that many sheep seven
why are you defending gay people
out of nowhere it's fine but it'd be
weird if i was like there's nothing
wrong with being black
black is beautiful and they're strong
and beautiful and strong people
it's like are you black i think you're
black
well
wow
[Music]
wow
it's gonna be a rock
don't really need it broski
always going to be wood i kind of want
that i do i do
okay things are shaping up for me what
the [ __ ] is orange doing
seven
oh my
god
he blocked his own rock
to steal from that guy
six
he's got a nine
nine road thing one two three four five
six seven
i need so many roads to catch up with
this [ __ ]
i need to [ __ ] oh i can't he doesn't
have anything there
i could do it here
it's really the only place i can do it
okay i got a sheep
cool
i got a sheep
so what i'll do is i'll get a brick
and i'll build a little settle seti
sediment
over here
and then i have eight points
and
hopefully i'll win la mel hellna hans
oh he's not gay where are you guys
talking in the chat about someone being
gay or something
dude this guy is so dumb i don't know
what the [ __ ] orange is doing
maybe he's gonna win
who knows
but i do not understand him
i could build another city but then i
need another point somehow
sieven
[ __ ]
i will [ __ ] you
you stole from that guy
i do not want that robber there
no
thank you
give me that
oh i can do it again
let me take from orange then
what can i even do with this [ __ ]
anyone want this i can build another
city
i'll have nine points
don't work
let me just buy a bunch of dev cards
i can only buy one or i could build a
road
sort of not really
ah
i guess that's useful that is useful
that's good that's good
okay i can win on the next turn
night
okay don't understand that move oh that
was useful
um that guy just said he isn't
that guy at all no offense but hans
doesn't want our jokes
can i give you a joke to try and kill
tony no yes i don't want those your
jokes please
i it's not anything personal i just i
can't have that in my head
okay i can win on this next turn i can
build
two
three
i need one more give me something oh i
win
you can call me a wiener because i just
weaned
weiner wiener
[ __ ]
gg this is how you're supposed to gg
okay watch and learn
i won the game and then i don't gg
preemptively so that people like is this
guy [ __ ] with me what's going on i
wait for the other guy to gg so i'm not
the one being like oh i was gonna win
anyways [ __ ]
uh flawless victory did i ever win on
stream on on live yet
um but yeah i mean i love jokes but
don't say hey you can use this one
that's like going up to someone and
being like
[ __ ] what is it like
oh you can use my joke
oh yeah sure
it's like going up to someone being like
a wood
wood uh carver and be like hey look i
made a little wood carving yeah you can
just say that one's yours that's yours
take it
you can put it in your museum
hey look
mozart i wrote you a little song yeah
that's that's yours just take it
that's it mozart original now
um so yeah i mean it's just
tens were really abnormally rolled
sevens were abnormally rolled
by me by the way tens and elevens
so whoever had a 10 or 11 had an
advantage
you [ __ ] had an advantage
these [ __ ] had these
[ __ ] at an advantage
there's another
this [ __ ] an advantage i did not
have that advantage
i did not have any other advantageous
things
sixes were slightly more advantageous
than eights i had both
damn what a what a beautiful beautiful
victory there's two victory points
hidden away
one and eight little cities right over
there i thought these things were
useless but it turns out it was useful
stream freezing for anyone nah
getting better internet they're telling
someone how to do their job
it's like yeah it is sort of like
telling someone how to do their job um
but it's like a personal thing where
you're saying these are my thoughts and
my ideas and to have someone else
be like
yeah you can just
this is this is just random and weird
right you just pick it up from anyone
and anywhere like that's what you think
you think i just like
i just exist and then people write me
jokes and i just repeat them online like
these jokes are born through
years of pain and sweat and not getting
laid
you can't not get laid for me i have to
not get laid on my own i can't have the
best internet known to man
yeah so there have been accusations of
joke theft all of which are false
pointed towards me there's a joke about
gay people about how uh most people are
not attracted if you're attract if
you're gay most of the gender you're
attracted to isn't attracted to you back
that was a joke i had before mark
normand did it on a special
and you know should i stop saying it
maybe
but it's not like i stole it
i was saying that joke and then i heard
mark norman do it and it's obviously
uh an obvious joke
i don't think it's that revolutionary
it's clever i hope
but um
yeah i mean if i came up with it
independently
um i don't really want to stop saying it
so i won't
but uh yeah i mean whatever
like if you think that's stealing
whatever i came what the independently i
have it recorded before his special came
out
um
and then another joke is a joke that
people say bobby lee had before me
and i'm sure he did
and i've
been to the parlor and i saw bobby lee a
bunch and he's definitely influenced me
but i honestly didn't think i stole it
but then i heard it and then it's pretty
similar
um
like the
the sewing machine
reference
so maybe i heard it and then i forgot
and then i thought of it again
and then i thought it was mine
um
so yeah i
didn't mean to i might have accidentally
stolen it or maybe it was just parallel
thinking it's
very similar so
maybe i heard it and then i repeated it
i honestly don't know but i do feel bad
i had no idea that it was a bobby lee
joke until i did it on kill tony and
someone posted it online
so yeah i mean i didn't mean to steal so
those are the two jokes that i think
people
have noticed are similar to others and
one of them
i've been doing before
that special came out so i don't think i
could have stolen it
and then the other one
i
didn't know
that it was
bobby lee's i didn't think i stole it
i
might have stolen it subconsciously but
not consciously i haven't
consciously stolen a joke and i never
would
i might have had parallel thinking with
mark norman and he might have put out a
special
with that joke on it because i think he
worded it slightly differently
and then bobby lee i might have just
seen him say it and then forgot and then
said it again
because i did that with this
bill hicks joke about crosses like
christians wearing crosses like if you
came down and saw
um
if jesus came down and saw people
wearing crosses it'd be like that's my
execution method i don't want to see
that and then i set it at an open mic
and then
and then i thought about it i was like
that sounds too familiar and then i
googled it and i was like oh [ __ ] that's
a bill hicks joke
but yeah i mean i might have had
parallel thinking and like forgot and
said it again but
you know i've done uh like 50 60 minutes
now
unkill tony
and uh you know a lot of those jokes are
not stolen the majority but besides
those two jokes
and i mean i might go for some easy [ __ ]
just because i'm trying to make jokes
and a lot of jokes that are funny are
easy
um
but
yeah i mean
people love people on the internet love
to accuse people of
stealing jokes
um and i mean you know good because then
it makes you better and makes you more
aware
and [ __ ]
and more
try hard
to write better jokes that are more
original
but uh also it's sort of a snide little
shitty little thing to be like excuse me
actually i heard that at another
comedy event
and um you know it's like
as long as you're coming up with the
jokes yourself
i
i think that's
like if you came up with it completely
independently i think it's good to good
to say um and if someone has a similar
joke
um
it's
unfortunate but
if two people have a similar joke i'd
say both
tell them even if you're in the same
scene like there's going to be different
audiences and [ __ ]
i don't think it's that important to
uh be that strict about it as long as
you have a good heart and you
did it came up with it the right way if
you have similar jokes like that
um obviously hopefully your jokes are
unique enough where they
they're adding something contributing to
the world of stand-up comedy
um but you know there's a lot of
time in between
starting out and being able to
contribute to stand-up comedy where you
have to
you know do jokes that are funny and
work and feel what it feels like to tell
funny jokes
where like if i saw two people in the
same scene telling the same joke or in
two different cities i'd be like it it
really doesn't matter no one's gonna
notice as long as you came up with it
purely
and you know how you came up with it and
you can reproduce coming up with jokes
like that
uh i would i'd say both
both people should tell him make the
show better if it's a good joke and it
improves the show you're not gonna tell
a good joke because some guys in [ __ ]
arkansas came up with a similar joke
i uh
i i think that misses the point of
what's good about comedy
and it's like sort of analytical and
overly
uh
pedantic
oh my god
hello
this is cool
the thing goes on forever
it never ends
you will forever be waving your hand
into the abyss
you're only a little tiny thing
of copy of facsimile of a facsimile i am
the real one you are fake
i am real
please
do not take me over hans have you done
your version of the aristocrats yet
the aristocrats
so there's a guy he's an aristocrat and
it's crazy
uh change is what people can't do humans
are creatures of habit
i like to joke about the mask and
smelling fear hans thanks fox tachikata
is this a goat wearing a mask
george lucas when he's chris rock big
he'll look for writers and bodyguards
maybe but joe rogan doesn't have writers
because without forgiveness you'll never
be happy in life trust me
what the [ __ ] are you talking about is
this the same guy that was talking about
how being gay is okay for no reason i
don't think you
steal hans i can trust you and you are
to steal from me i don't care you got
unlimited forgiveness with me says rob
james because without forgiveness you'll
never be happy in life
trust me
okay thanks i guess i'm i'll try to use
that
everyone knows so many jokes it's easier
to forget
okay i don't know what's going on i find
the same applies right to me it's very
difficult to compose without things
someone else wrote this before
yes we have to have the ability to
forget
if we can't forget then we will remember
and uh it's bad
to remember forever you should need to
be able to forget like in
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind
which
had a different
whatever different moral
like i don't i'm green right here
how do i get rid of that
but uh do you know what the risk crack
just joke is it's like a joke the way
you try to make it as disgusting as
possible in your own way and then it all
ends the same way
that's the aristocrats
were the aristocrats
um i saw a documentary about it i was
looking when i was a child and i had no
taste of my own i would go online and be
like what internet please tell me what a
good movie is and they were like this is
a good movie this is a peak of our
culture
this is what we want to reward this is
what we feel good about saying we reward
so they recommended aristocrats and then
they were like whatever
i was like yeah it's fine i guess
there's just a chance for comedians to
jerk each other off and
be like man we're such comedians look at
us comedianizing
do you think it's okay when tony calls
you autistic on stage because i think
it's kind of mean he keeps saying it
i think that tony is very ableist and he
is not very sensitive to my disability
of extreme autism
and
i've counted how many times he said it
he said it 74 times
once on january 23rd
2021
and it hurt my feelings thusly
my feelings were hurt
in a way
where you could describe my
emotions as lugubrious and
sacrosanct
so are you really asian
i mean do i have to be
is that important
um
am i offended when tony calls me
autistic
no
i'm not offended at all
i feel seen i feel like someone actually
knows me now
um i wish i was autistic i wish that's
what was wrong with me
then
it'd be
nice i guess
look at how this green gatorade water
bottle blends in
because it's set to catch green
i wonder why green it was the color i
guess it's because not a lot of people
use green
drop the asian act man
okay
let me just
take all this off
my eyes large
it's a part of me intrinsically it goes
down deep to the bone i cannot extract
the asian from me
i am asian and asian am i
and asians are i
the autistics
um
i mean i could try to come up with an
aristocrats
version it's just
i don't know they're not
trot on well trod territory
i'd rather do something new and
interesting like
stealing jokes from mark normand
which i didn't do it's parallel thinking
relax
um
so what do you guys think about
poverty
and the reduction of
the standard of living
the autistic cats
i think a lot of our problem has to do
with people not having money
and a lot of our problems would be fixed
if everyone had money that's what i
think
homelessness why is homelessness a
problem you think it's because people
have
like they just hate homes
they hate having a nice
standard of living
or do you think it's because they don't
have enough money
why is drug addiction a problem you
think it's because people just have too
much money
or do you think it's because they don't
have enough money and they're sad and
they hurt their bodies
because society doesn't tell them that
they're wanted so then they treat their
body shitty
pollen is bad here in atl too maybe
that's what's going on maybe there's
like a pollen issue
because my nose has been weird
um
[Music]
you know robberies thefts crime
what are they doing they're trying to
get more money how could you fix that
problem by giving them more money all
you would have to do is pay people
fairly you don't even have to give
people money all you have to do is make
sure people are getting paid for the
work that they do and then
poverty
and homelessness
and wealth inequality and social angst
and
people acting out and shooting people
will disappear it will
be gone because we don't live in a
course of society built around
exploitation but unfortunately that is
not happening because people want to
keep their money they're like this is
mine i don't want to give it to anybody
else i'm going to keep this level of
inequality going but if we just released
the gates
and made it an equal society and paid
people fairly
for the work they did instead of giving
mcdonald employees the minimum amount
possible
legally and giving all the rest of the
money to the top
executives and ceos instead of that if
you just paid the people for the amount
of work they did and the amount of
benefits they they brought
the company
all of our problems would be fixed there
would be no more
uh
homelessness
if people got paid fairly for the work
they did then they could just work
and get a house or a living quarter and
they wouldn't become homeless in the
first place a lot of our social ills a
lot of our depression and anxiety would
go away
a lot of our you know mental illnesses a
lot of
you know anti-social behavior mass
shootings school shootings uh invading
other countries
would disappear if we just paid people
fairly for the work that they did but we
don't we try to pay them as little as
possible
and try to
make as much money off of people as
possible and cheat each other as much as
possible
it's like we're all cutting weight
i'm cheating you so you gotta cheat me
uh texas is bad pollen
that's 15 a minute before covet would
have done wonders
that 15
min
before covered would have done wonders
yeah but it that's even too low
and i mean
some scandinavian countries don't have a
minimum wage because they just pay
people fairly
so maybe we could just do that
drugs and hanging out with joe rogan
i just have to work every day that's all
but i know i have faith i will get the
bag one day
i said we're ready that's all
but i know i have faith
i know
but i know i have faith
you know you have faith don't you just
have faith you have to know you have
faith i will get the bag one day
i mean
how many people think that
and how many people actually achieve
that
and is there a number that you can use
to find out how likely it is that you
will become successful in a given
society oh yeah there is it's called
social mobility and america is 27th in
that
there's 26 other countries where it's
easier to get ahead by
working hard so like if you can change
that number maybe you should make it
more fair so that you can
get um
get a fair
payment for your [ __ ]
instead of just working hard blindly you
should
be aware of what you're working hard in
and
uh play the game that is at in front of
you instead of just like a
cow
just putting one foot ahead of the next
every day
and also just look at how companies
treat people who have been working for
them for 30 years
they fire them whenever they can
they do whatever it takes to make as
much money and if that requires you to
be destitute when you're old they will
do that
to have faith in this system
and the way things are now and to work
your life away for this system and hope
that they're fair
i think is a
foolhardy and i think it's
been proven to not be that good
uh overall
um
[Music]
and i think that uh yeah i mean if you
want to do that i think that's fine you
should be allowed to do that to just
work hard but i think working hard is
not the end-all be-all choosing what to
work hard in
is more important in some in a lot of
instances
because working hard is nice and good
but you should also
pick the right way to work hard because
if you just work hard
it's going to be inefficient people are
going to take advantage of that and use
it to make themselves rich instead of
if you pick something that you want to
get good at and stuff you all must have
send this homeless a space yeah give
them a little vacation show them what
the world is all about
what the universe is all about
um do you ever dream any of your jokes i
think so
yeah i'm like man that was funny i
should say that in real life and on
stage
in real life
on a real life stage
let's find a cool background
i was on i was in tiananmen square
earlier
oh my god look how sexy that black is
right there with eight points jesus one
two three four five six seven eight
okay tiananmen square is nice but i need
something else
um what's a cool place
mount everest
emojis
let's be on mount everest open link in
newtow
i like
about the view from everest
um
so i have a girlfriend now she's very
beautiful and cute and
awesome and sexy and i'm just glad that
i don't have to [ __ ]
talk to people and try to get laid
it's [ __ ]
i hate it
i hate all of it i think that
it's a horrible horrible thing to put
yourself through
and i'm glad i'm out of it i would not
want to do that again
i'm having a good time not doing that
not talking to you crazy [ __ ]
and doing whatever the [ __ ] i want to do
i think uh being in the dating world is
horrible
i did not enjoy it and i'm glad to be
out of it i'm so happy to be out of it
people are willing to be exploited sadly
because the conditions of society make
it so difficult to get by
we can change that
we don't just have to work hard in the
system that we're in put our heads down
and accept the way things are we can
change the society that we're in to make
it a more fair more fun
more meritocratic one instead of just
being like this is the way it is let's
just really get good at
doing things the way it is it's like we
got the same brain on it's just my eyes
are wide enough to see the bigger
picture
well enlighten us please
psychological warfare dog all our people
need help personally in their mind money
will only actually i can make a case
kill them
oh jesus i don't know what happened did
you like copy paste some other sentence
but it's a conversation more than just a
couple sentences will there be any skit
regarding this
regarding wealth inequality
yeah let's do a skit about it i don't
understand why people call
jokes and stand up comedy skits no one
has ever said that in professional
comedy
about
jokes hundreds of different performing
the metaverse i have an events coming in
this
and turtle and if you ever want to set
that up
i like performing in front of people i
miss your squad streams but i'm glad you
have been
too busy to stream congrats on whatever
is going on all this knowledge for real
right
but hard work always pays off watch my
dad has a story as an immigrant [ __ ] my
dad is my hero no cap
immigrants are great but their way of
dealing with the world is old and
not updated
and working hard
is very helpful but
for every success story is a thousand
unsuccess stories where people work hard
and we're not rewarded
so
um
working hard is a prerequisite
and then
where you choose to work hard
is
also something that you should consider
just working hard is not good enough
everyone works hard working hard is a
natural part of being a human
um
working hard is important
and we should all
do it
but then there's more than just working
hard
uh job security labor laws
a metaverse event amen buddy
facts hans d kim i agree with that
or a hard statement can we see
can you see my beautiful girlfriend yeah
sure
um but only if she consents
daniel miller i know what you mean about
the faith but faith is something that is
manifested i decay how to to
actually teach someone to have faith
it's just a feeling you get that comes
out of nowhere
well
indescribable feelings
um
banana
and curry on pizza or mustard on vanilla
ice cream
i agree with that hans kim
there's a million stories about the
success story facts
yeah so um everest is cool
you'll see here on everest this little
section of everest this is what i call
the flat plains of everest
we're just we're just observing this
beautiful beautiful everest right here
and then over here
this is what i call
peak number one
pink number
two peak number seven
[Music]
this is the sky
okay so
i'm done
i'm [ __ ] tired of [ __ ] i stayed up
way too late doing this
i feel like an idiot
i gave you people way too much
content
and
i should have kept it hidden
squirreled it away
instead i gave it all to you people
for free no not for free i think it's
monetized i hope it's mine i'm gonna
monetize it
uh
i made money
oh and also
um you can donate money
no one's done that yet
but it's that's totally a possibility
uh green screen cost me
like 30 40 50 bucks look it up on amazon
this little stand
but i gotta go
no bro you're amazing bro i love your
lives
dog um
your english
confuses me sometimes but i appreciate
your sentiments and i think i understand
what you're saying
everyone is equal it's guaranteed they
will be equally
miserable good we should all be equally
miserable we're all
part of the same species we're a hive
mind
i mean tired
okay
have a good night
uh let me see something funny before i
leave
poopy taco butts
in the
lay airport
are
farting and [ __ ] the ass [ __ ]
hungzman